yo what's up guys before this episode
starts let me give a little disclaimer
after we finish this episode april looks
at me and marty and says you guys didn't
ask me anything positive
all we talked about was the bad stuff so
to clarify guys april actually has a
very successful realtor company she
sells houses on the ocean she raises
three kids and marty she's doing very
well so just to clarify guys she she's
not just the person that she used to be
take that away from this episode if you
take anything
[Music]
perfect yo what's up guys welcome back
to the dope as usual podcast my name is
thomas dobaziola this is marty o'neil
don't say the f-word yeah
you're already on it we're trying to do
monetize
guys we're here for a special episode
today we have the ninja turtle savior we
have
the newscaster this is april o'neil this
is marty's wife reporting live reporting
live do you say that all the time do you
really yeah your kids do your kids watch
it no
they don't really get it they don't they
get it they've already had they've had
faith but they don't think it's like
super duper cool no
no i'll be pissed yeah they don't really
get it i don't have true appreciation
for what
we always say that's how we spot the
cool people by like when they they look
at our idea at the airport and then they
what the
literally like that's where i get
stopped at is the airport they'll look
at my id and they'll be like
no
way you should just start saying you're
a reporter
what do you do i'm a reporter oh
[ __ ]
that'd be tight as hell actually
i actually um
i worked at uh this one place
waitressing and the dude was like so
blown away that was my name and he's
like i swear to god i used to like tape
my two fingers down in the middle to
pretend i was a turtle
that [ __ ]
as a customer was he a weirdo no he i
worked with him
yeah he was just obsessed with the ninja
turtles and he thought that was real
cool was it [ __ ] from step brothers and
i used to pretend to be a t-rex my dad
said get a [ __ ] job
oh sorry youtube damn
[ __ ]
um
guys what's up what's up how are we
gonna how are we gonna get into this
remember
there's no cameras here
none at all there's no cameras there's
no comfortable we're chilling really
chilling there's just water in these
cups just
water
refreshing
couple friends celebrate yeah
she has his house is officially done
it's not officially done i mean you can
live there yeah we can definitely live
there and live now you have a fridge we
do have a regular person sized fridge
it's not the mini biggest staircase of
all time
you could drive a [ __ ] truck up there
you talked about this before yeah okay
yes you could totally fit a truck okay
isn't that kind of [ __ ] up about that
um
so i'm gonna get straight into this
marty
keep your [ __ ] talking to a minimum oh
i'm here to observe and produce yeah
okay okay because marty gets
marty goes hard
i imagine that's how he used to play
basketball just relentless that's what
my opponents he talks a lot of [ __ ] abra
but not in a mean way not a domestic
violence way no it's like a loving yeah
i love you and i'm being a real dick
right now
kind of what she means to say is i'm
super [ __ ] funny and that's super
dope and and he dunks he dunks on me
all that [ __ ] right he crossed me
that's all those words um so let's get
straight into this
it's kind of odd because
this is more of a
you know what i'm saying it's like the
rosie episode it's more like and we're
all just chilling right now i feel like
we probably should have dressed off top
the whole like
atom 22 is going to be coming in next
week oh yes yes rescheduled that'll be
next week so for everybody thinking that
this is the episode yeah a lot of people
all right let's just move on yeah
it's just me better yeah let's go you
ready hold on let me get my
[ __ ]
dead
let's go you got to label them you have
a label maker i got two men i got too
many songs i got banks of them i gotta
scroll through you ready i'm ready are
you sure i think so where'd you grow up
kind of
complicated get out of here where did
you grow up this was not gonna stop
i grew up uh
in the suburbs of buffalo
your whole life
my whole life
for real for real so why did i think you
were from
new york
city city no closer there i'm [ __ ]
tripping okay so you grew up in buffalo
with your i know because like we just
asked your mom and her boyfriend or step
your stepdad
so they're in town how long has she been
with him or were you with with your mom
and dad together
as a kid um
no so
uh
my
my dad and my mom
were never together really it was just
like a product of them hooking up
um
and they split up
they saw each other on and off until i
was like two and then my mom and my
stepdad have been together
mad long actually probably like 30 years
oh [ __ ] yeah so i
i've known him since i was like five
um
but i grew up
until i was about five i live with my
grandma my mom had me at 18
and she
went off to college so i basically
whoa [ __ ] lifetime movies yeah
rosie i've seen that movie with you
that's crazy
so she said [ __ ] it you guys got to take
care of my daughter while i get an
education
she did an okay thing like right
so growing up i didn't realize that was
an okay thing i was very resentful
until for a long time and so i mean so
basically i grew up and i have an aunt
who is only like two and a half years
older than me
so i grew up with her
until i was about five with my grandma
and then my mom met my stepdad
and
um they had just bought a house so
she decided she was like ready for a kid
and
basically took me back from grandma how
long and what age five
oh okay yeah
oh that sucks yeah so i didn't i didn't
have like that
that initial you know like bonding with
your mother and all that i have like no
memories of her until i was like
maybe six
um but now looking back like i realized
that's what she had to do to better her
life and
all that so
is your mom cool
growing up um
what is this situation
so she
we have a great relationship now growing
up it was wasn't good at all
i think there was like even from a young
age there was that resentment of like
you're just taking me away from
everything that i know
and now all of a sudden you got this new
husband
and
you know just
kind of going back and forth like so my
dad had visitation still my dad would
come get me every other weekend it was
tumultuous because her stepdad and her
dad were at odds
well you said didn't your dad didn't
like each other no they hated each other
whoa hold on
your stat is your dad awesome wait your
dad's cool right my dad's super cool
yeah your dad's cool so you were on his
side
i was a little too cool so growing up it
was awesome because i had like no rules
i could do whatever the [ __ ] i wanted
um and he lived in the same town no he
lived about an hour and a half away
in 1955 he lived because you drive back
into the future yeah so my dad
like
it was a lot different like my dad lived
in like this country ass he still lives
there this country has super small town
everybody knows each other and it's like
kind of like where you grew up like
everybody has nothing to do so they're
all [ __ ] doing drugs and
meth and heroin and getting pregnant
stuff to do nothing nothing to do
nothing to do exactly so um
you know i had a lot of friends
at my dad's that
they were pregnant at 14. they were on
they were on their fourth kid by
18 18. yeah and then had them all taken
away
yeah trailer part time trailer part time
yeah okay so you have the white people
version of merced yeah okay
i'm i'm imagining trailer park boys
so
what i love that show
but it was a little surreal because like
it felt like it was almost too much it
was a little too much
because it was so much like that
yeah
so you were that badass kid running
around breaking bottles
basically oh my god so from five
to
18 you're allowed to go see your dad on
the weekends or
so every weekend you have a free pass to
go do crazy exactly so it was like i was
like live in double lives because my mom
was super strict
my stepdad was super strict he was a
correction officer
so he was the cool was he cool girl he
okay not growing up no like we hated
each other growing up we were at odds
all the time it was it was just tough
all around because you know like i said
i was taken from my my grandma's house
um just expected to kind of adapt to
this new life so
they basically took me back and um
you know i had this new dad basically
that i was supposed to just
listen to and do all this [ __ ] with and
and my dad hated him
because he hated my dad because he was
like i probably
i don't really know they were like at
odds on like how to raise me and like
he's a corrections officer imagine he
was going with another dude
yeah he was like i think my dad was most
like
there's another guy trying to step in
and take my place and like tell my
daughter what to do and you know all
that which
didn't sit well with my dad
um so they were constantly at odds
which
um
in the middle of that i was so in the
middle of all and then your step dad
kind of looks at you like man [ __ ]
you're dead
i think it gets mad at you about it kind
of yeah i would imagine because he
couldn't understand like and let me
start by saying like i don't
fault him
my stepdad for for any of that now like
we've had many of conversations now as
as an adult where he's like apologized
and
we're really cool now and honestly he's
like he's a great grandparent to my kids
we get along very well
um but growing up it it wasn't like that
at all i think he couldn't understand
why
i loved my dad so much
oh
got you because he's hearing from my mom
like what a piece of [ __ ] my dad is and
you know so your mom and your dad are
not on concerns whatsoever no i don't
know and never have been
they grew to not like each other in two
years yeah
they're like completely opposite that's
the product of just like going out and
hooking up and then getting pregnant
when you're 17 years old you know you're
you're you're stuck dealing with
somebody that you necessarily never even
liked in the first place
now you got a kid
okay so they don't like each other your
has this correction officer going hey i
don't like that guy because she tells me
he's a piece of [ __ ] right how about now
um they
for my sake and for my kid's sake
they'll
they'll get along like they were both at
our wedding
and
it was a big deal for you we had to come
up to our wedding yeah it was a big deal
but it was like kind of it was a lot of
drama beforehand i had to like talk to
both of them is it gonna be okay
you
know no it never got better oh wow okay
so growing up
super strict you're definitely going to
start rebelling against
yo do [ __ ] stay home be home at this
time versus what's your day you guys do
whatever [ __ ] you want whatever i wanted
so what's your childhood like living
with your dad doing whatever you want
what are you doing at
12 13. because before that you're just
bottle breaking kids
eating candy and doing stupid [ __ ]
so
my dad would come get me every other
weekend religiously
and
start like from two i was like 12 years
old maybe even 11 my dad was letting me
smoke cigarettes oh [ __ ]
yeah so he'd come get me as soon as i
hopped in the car he'd have to pack
cigarettes and i just light one and
are you the only one by the way
i'm
his only child um
but he does have two other children so i
have two half-brothers but
i don't really know them too much are
you the oldest
i'm the oldest oh so growing up is just
you and he's letting you hey smoke a
cigarette yeah basically he's she's the
only one that he was there for basically
as like as a dad gotcha no [ __ ] so
you're sitting there smoking cigs loving
that [ __ ] and chilling
feeling like the cool and then so what
are you doing
are you i'm assuming you started
drinking and chilling early
super early yeah so i was 11 and 12
basically going down there like this is
my my free time this is my escape
because
i had you know
just
two different
lifestyles essentially so i got a taste
of that and i think the only reason like
my dad would come get me and he'd still
go out and chill with his friends and
take me to parties and all that oh my
dad okay so i i get you yeah so he would
you know just to give you kind of like a
backup he
he would go and mind you i do
i say this
i i love my dad of course like now
looking back on things he
of course doesn't think any of it was
right but he didn't know any better
either he was young as [ __ ] and that's
the lifestyle that he grew up with oh he
was 17.
he was a little bit older he was like 20
i think when he had still a kid having
kids exactly um and that's where he grew
up like that's what everybody else is
doing their kids around
um so my dad would like still go to
parties and you know he'd he'd drink a
lot and
there's been a couple times where he let
me drive home on his lap when he's like
just to make sure
when he's drinking you're singing
i'll be in the light how [ __ ] cool is
this like
[Laughter]
so i'm like 9 10 years old already like
driving home
you know and i'm thinking i'm like this
is [ __ ] awesome oh you might as well
have a leather jacket on right here
um but i remember like there was um one
of his really good friends they were we
were coming back from the party and he
was like oh watch loose and he like let
me drive home and his friend is like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's like this is not cool he's like no
it's fine she'll get us home safe like
that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
that's frank gallagher from shane yes so
that's another show that gives me
anxiety because
i'm like this is so similar to my
[ __ ] life
um
but
yeah so
growing up i would go there on the
weekends i already got a taste of like
freedom at a really early age like
college life college life so i was like
12 years old hanging out with like 19 20
year olds
12 and 13. like that was because i had
an older cousin too
um
and i would hang out with him and all
his friends and you know just
experience some [ __ ] i probably
shouldn't have at 12 and 13. um
but
what are you going to do
so you're running around with all these
older kids
and then so then back to the ultra
strict
yes so then i'd spend the weekend doing
literally i'm living a double life
um mom and stepdad know what you're
doing no because i couldn't i could
never because they already don't like
each other they're at odds my mom is
already trying to keep me away from my
dad she was always in trouble though
why
oh because you're being a jerk to your
mom
yeah exactly i'd come home like not
giving a [ __ ] not listening spark a cig
yeah
literally like before i was
waiting for the bus and i'd be like in
the garage like smoking on cigarettes
like at 12. yeah it's just
it wasn't a good situation but that's
how i grew up too so i understand yeah
so
i'm assuming if your dad's
a couple years older than you yeah i
mean he's like what 34 and you're a
teenager almost
well you are a teenager 14 right you had
you had 20.
when does he start letting you drink
oh i mean i don't know that he
necessarily was like
exactly he just didn't like turn the
blind eye i mean there's so
in um
in eighth grade i actually got kicked
out of my mom's house
um i
stole the family van
at eighth grade
yeah well it was actually seventh grade
the end of seventh grade
going into eighth i i took her van for a
little joy ride i was like
going and picking up my friends and
everything and then i like hit into a
tree
no lead-up
you know we're just hanging out eating
ice cream and then i had a tree
i did not expect that you wrecked the
van i didn't wreck it i like pulled out
and i hit a tree and it like busted
i just like clipped the side and it
busted the headlight out in somebody's
driveway i was pulling out
i thought okay like reversing and i
turned it too hard
she doesn't [ __ ] all the time so did he
i still current day like i like to say
i'm a good driver but he'll disagree so
okay hold on
back to what we were talking about
you get kicked out because you took the
van
you messed up the car did you go home
before they were back and then you had
to explain that you had taken it
um so i didn't explain anything i was
just hoping that they wouldn't notice
i was on the driver's side i just pulled
the van back in the um
back in the garage and then
i think it was like actually it was like
the summer and it was a couple days
before the start of eighth grade maybe
or no no no it was it was the end of
seventh grade it was still school was
still going on
and then she came i was at soccer or
something and she came
to soccer to pick me up and i knew about
the van yeah
i knew
you know oh [ __ ] she she knows and she
just she picked me up she's like you
gotta go live with your dad that's it
pretty much i mean i had already been
kind of i mean she should have honestly
like was your mom that had to be the
[ __ ] really reckless um
no that's probably why
maybe she'd beat the share of you it's a
controversial thing i'm sorry i feel
like you should get like this i don't
really mean this but just a thought like
if you were to get one good smack a kid
per year they knew you had it and you
could use it
okay but in my mind
seriously because i feel like it would
go so [ __ ] far it's like a special
meter building yeah he's out he's out
it's like a freebie yeah if i don't use
it for the year you know i got six i've
got six built up that's you know i could
kill you i can beat you to death legally
yo so listen back your mom never beat
your ass she she smacked me one time
when you called her a [ __ ] or something
right across the face i don't remember
what it was about but i literally
smacked her right back
like that's the kind of like i was
already at the point where like i just
didn't give a [ __ ] about anything and
like you know me and my mom we had our
issues and everything but now that i'm
adult i'm like geez you had to [ __ ]
put up with oh now you're like oh that
[ __ ] 10 year old daughter exactly
exactly
now i have listen up to that's the
advice would you give that to all people
or all teenagers teenage girls be nice
to your mom because you're going to have
a daughter that's going to be just like
you exactly you don't realize until you
have kids you're like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i
remember i did that
[Laughter]
i said that before
yeah but now it's like oh my kid hits me
oh we're fighting but back then you're
like oh [ __ ]
so real quick once you hit her did you
run
no oh damn you were brave oh my god i
would have ran immediately had you
already drawn a dude at this point no
not yet i didn't get into that and yo
the first time i ever punched somebody
in their face a dude was i was 14
but it was at my aunt's graduation party
so she was
14 yeah and she was like just turned 17
or something she had just graduated and
this we were all drinking at her
graduation party
and this kid showed up
and he did he did something he like
kicked he was just coming to be an
[ __ ] and he kicked one of my sister's
soccer balls like
out of the yard just something stupid
and um
my aunt told him leave he wouldn't leave
and i just i just punched him in his
face and his lips started bleeding and
no he didn't not this
this time the guy didn't punch me back
but this this this time
okay so not to get too crazy
somebody else punched you back can you
tell me the situation
what happened
okay let me start by saying like it's
not okay
no it's not it's not at all okay like i
i just didn't give a [ __ ] about anything
i'm like whatever like don't talk [ __ ]
to me i'm just gonna punch you in your
face and that's how i grew up like
watching like my dad how they all
handled situations on that there were no
words they were like i'm gonna [ __ ]
choke you out i'm gonna fight you
whatever well your dad grew up fighting
in dirt circles
pretty much yeah
i could see that like my cousin
and my dad literally fist fought each
other and like choked each other out to
the point where
it was like somebody was about to die
kind of situation constant thing yeah it
was um so this just conflict resolution
wasn't really um
my thing yeah um
so that's just what i would do but um
there was this one time i was downtown
and this guy started talking [ __ ]
i don't remember about what but i just
went out and i punched him in the face
and he punched me back
yeah it was it was quite bad it was hurt
more
me for sure
i have no idea yeah i yeah it was bad my
jaw like i thought my jaw was broken oh
yeah he punched you
[ __ ] yeah you can't you can't no you
can't hit grown-ups literally
i used to think it was like you know i
had no care in the world i felt
invincible i could do what i want say
what i wanted but you really can't
do that without there's there's
consequences to actions and you can't
expect as a female to just walk up and
blast dudes in their face with no
reaction thank you so much for saying
that
i see so many girls punch dudes in the
face and when they get hit they go
but i'm a girl i'm like yeah but you're
also an adult and you have their thought
process don't punch them in their
[ __ ] face you shouldn't hit girls
right you should have dudes either and
of course like some dudes there's a way
like you don't have to full-on blast
them in their face but yeah like a
smoosh or like yeah there's a lot of
different things she transitioned into
arm wrestling [ __ ] there
what
i did so that was like my thing you used
to arm wrestle people mm-hmm she used to
get you're the super [ __ ] face girl
she's a small conversation
smoking newport
arm wrestling [ __ ] the death oh
my god where are you
tattoos
what the [ __ ] i've never heard this oh
my god
okay marty help me out yeah you know way
more than i do bad [ __ ] i'm
yeah literally i'd be out at the bar and
it was like watching my friends i am
pretty strong like a lot of people
wouldn't think so they're like yo
[ __ ] arm wrestle you and then you
know they'll do that like
they're trying really insane like what
the [ __ ] girl just beats you in front of
so i have beat dudes before arm
wrestling and this one guy i'd be at the
bar my friends would be like start bets
they'll be like hey do you think my
friend can can beat your friend and
they'd we'd like bet on money
and uh there was this one time that i
actually i did beat the dude and his
friend got so
mad at him he's like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you he's talking so much [ __ ]
yeah so absolutely he lost his money he
did yeah
what's going on what town are you when
you just you know ringer
what the [ __ ] chilling in bars arm
wrestling i don't know it's just like
punching people in the face
scare the [ __ ] out of me
oh my god i just oh
i you guys don't know on the camera that
shit's deep in your brain these
headphones are [ __ ] loud it's like it
goes into here
so it's scary to share me when i don't
know what's coming on
okay
sorry we're we're way off track she had
a girl retaliate one good time also you
had a what yeah
she had a girl retaliate
retaliate oh wait because i beat her and
i'm wrestling and she was so pissed off
that i beat her she
like took my head to go slam it on the
table that's not what i'm talking about
oh i was like if you're beating dude's
ass you're definitely beating three to
four times the amount of girls asses too
oh yeah i mean probably lifetime i
probably been in like
25 fights ugh but girls
i've only lost maybe like one
no that's when you should play that
excuse me
yeah exactly
oh my god for everyone in the car
not watching come watch this and i need
them to put the face
to what's happening right now yeah i
know so
if you're at so did you go to school
like were you in high school and stuff i
was in high school did you get kicked
off of beating people's asses um so it
wasn't i didn't fight a lot of people in
high school i think i got one fight in
high school one in middle school this is
all after here this is downtown
yeah downtown buffalo
yeah i was trying to lead you into the
time the girl stabbed you okay oh
[ __ ]
yeah is there an arm wrestling situation
no it wasn't just see that's why i
didn't know what you're talking about
she couldn't take it she was too [ __ ]
embarrassed
so please give me the background okay so
this is
mind you this is a long time ago i was a
different person yeah now you're a
different person yeah um so me and my
friends we would that was like our thing
we would go downtown buffalo chippewa
the bars are open until four o'clock in
the morning jesus yeah not i mean
nothing good happens
in the morning it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] so
it's always a [ __ ] show um
so we'd go downtown and like i don't
know like it just always
any time anybody would run their mouth
or even sometimes they'd run their mouth
to my friends my friends would come get
me
i was like the [ __ ] bouncer for
everybody
and this was this is that situation like
i wasn't even fighting for myself it was
over something my friend did
and we're fighting
we both get kicked out and then we i i
run to the back
to approach her again which i shouldn't
have done hindsight 20 20. um
and she were like fighting again
and she just she so stabbed when i say
stab i did get stabbed but it was with a
nail filer
wow
she stabbed me in my arm with a nail
filer
oh
we had to go through all your meat on
your arm yeah it did
my arms started bleeding like
you know wait so she stabbed you and
then you went all right i'm done
fighting or did you keep no it was like
that the adrenaline i kept fighting her
really i never realized
oh so um
after that
i
i had to get stitches i had to go to the
hospital and get stitches and i think
after that
it put it in perspective to me like i'm
might die yeah like somebody that that's
what i'm saying like you never know
especially today
you never know what somebody has with
them what they're willing to do
it
it's it's not worth it fighting
people not worth it
trying to
be tough and
just
i think
kathy over here conference show
why are you beating everyone's ass were
you were you a tomboy growing up or is
your dad raising rough as [ __ ] wasn't i
think i just um
not that you have to be tomorrow to be
people's asses but what what letter just
one day you wouldn't know what i was
like i just couldn't i just couldn't
tolerate people talking [ __ ] to me
yeah so i feel like if you're gonna talk
[ __ ] to me i'm just gonna beat you up
it's kind of how i
played it but i did make actually
there's a couple times i i beat someone
up and the girl became my best friend
like she was like super apologetic she
got
hit yes like she got beat up and then
she's like respect you know
she tapped you up and you walked away
yeah i
actually had some really good friends
that way but what
oh sorry i can't be friends with
somebody that beat me up
i look jared like shut the [ __ ] up
don't don't hit me
[ __ ] you you know what i mean like open
the door
hey you owe me that money i ain't giving
you how could you be friends with
somebody they can beat the [ __ ] or that
sorry i just put that into perspective
that's insane
if you're in jail you have a
ring of people following you that you
beat up
[Laughter]
could you imagine this
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] funny to imagine
god
okay sorry we went well i think i think
i'd do good in jail that's why like i'm
this is where trump gets it uh yeah
that's right
about the time i went to jail a couple
times
i said cam and you talk about bringing
up the jail
go right into it so why are you in jail
um
oh my god
let's see i think we already talked
about this actually but it was like
oh wait for the for the for the credit
card thing and pizza yeah so okay so
this is what happens when you just like
live your life recklessly
you don't you know i i didn't have the
best childhood or the best examples
growing up at childhood so
i just kind of took that as like
got in with the wrong crowd
and
i had my own place we were like
living the life and
um one of my roommates was using like
stolen credit cards and getting stuff
sent to the house and everything
and um
they ended up because i was the one on
the lease basically well this is a hotel
it was the lease
that's where you get in trouble yeah
that's why i got in trouble and i didn't
you know so they so they came to you and
goes well you're getting charged with
fraud
right
exactly
you know
so you went to jail how'd you get out of
that uh a lawyer
oh nice it was horrible yeah it was it's
right with you guys terrible it was
right when we met and it was like two
years almost three years removed from
me hanging out with those people like at
some point in my life i was like i don't
want this for myself anymore
you know i had to make that decision it
did yeah it was like a whole
investigation because the guy who was
doing it
he was already being investigated for
like um
drugs like shipping drugs to detroit and
stuff
so it was like a whole i had the fbi
show up to my house because of this guy
did you remember
yeah he was my roommate how did you meet
him
i don't even know like just through
friends of friends his girlfriend
actually was
my roommate and then he was you know the
boyfriend but i knew him being oh
yeah quack
he just used that spot up mm-hmm yeah
it's like fbi came so he's not shipping
good [ __ ] he's not shipping right
if they already know and come to the
house he's going to prison
so i think they were like more focused
on that case and they weren't giving a
[ __ ] about like credit card theft or
anything like that they were just
willing to stick that to anybody who
they could prove yeah you know and i was
the one living at the house and i did
stay at one of the hotels that he had
booked
oh
yeah exactly
so
it came at a point in my life it was
really tough because i had already
decided that's you know
i didn't want to be involved with people
like that anymore and
i had met marty
and then i was was i pregnant
no it was too early on for the the night
you did in jail but then there was a
whole stretch of going back and forth
like court appointments and all that
[ __ ] at which point you were probably
knocked up seeing as though you got
knocked up immediately
marty went
oh my god
you had that ready
so that's not the only time you went to
jail um no
so that time we had was that the first
time gosh i can't so this is what
happens when you do too much [ __ ] in
your life it starts like
you don't your brain only has so much
space to like
hold memories so
um
that i think it was the first time so
then we got marty i just met marty you
were driving your dad's like
shitty green station wig
and he was taking me back and forth to
the court dates and i had gotten a
lawyer
the lawyer i had a warrant out for my
arrest the reason i found out i had a
warrant for my rest is because my friend
mary
she was dating a cop at the time
and she called me i was like yo i just
had him run your name just like run both
our names and your you popped up you
have a warrant
she like screenshot it and everything
actually so i had already went to jail
before because there was a screenshot of
my last mug shot
damn for what
traffic tickets
you just didn't pay them when did you
chill for it
yeah so buffalo don't play
like if you don't pay your parking
tickets
yeah they put a bench warrant out on you
i don't know if i paid my last breaking
ticket
we did you did okay
that would be such a bummer yeah so
and that's the thing like you go to jail
and buffalo they're not there isn't like
you know separate spot for like traffic
ticket offenders and whatever
they put it is such a shitty situation
there
they put you in a room
like a tiny ass room with probably there
was like probably six or seven women
with me and
there's a toilet literally right in the
middle of the room with like a small
little pony wall
and i'm in there and
this girl was like oh what are you in
for i'm like uh traffic tickets
trafficking trafficking traffic traffic
tickets traffic tickets
and then i heard her tell she's like i
stabbed my [ __ ] boyfriend or whatever
so i'm in there with like all these
people that
are doing some real heinous [ __ ] and
then
what really sucked also is i'm in there
with this lady who has like clear
stomach issues she's like i had half my
intestine removed they're supposed to
give me my medication
they aren't giving me my medication so
she's literally [ __ ] the whole time
in this tiny cell with all of us
together and the toilet is right [ __ ]
there how long were you in jail for that
for the children just overnight oh so it
wasn't bad i wasn't like you know
going to fed prison or anything
but um
i just remember it being such a terrible
experience
and then thinking i'm never not gonna
pay my tickets again you know you learn
your lesson and it was like they take
you in this room to sleep and they all
they give you is this like blue mat and
it smell like piss it was like
disgusting no blankets no nothing
and it was freezing and it was like the
worst night of my life
um
so i said i'd never go back but then two
years later like the thing from two
years i had caught up with me
and then i went back again
it was just was it a night or two night
that was just it was a night i think i
don't know that sure was sad
it was really sad because i was already
like a different person at that time you
already changed i was a changed girl
oh i was working my magic we were
getting there yeah
yeah he was my he's my savior honestly a
little knight in shining armor marty
over there a little knight in 42 pants
in size 42's night and shorts in
oh i thought you were lighting a joint
what
no way
the ambulance would be here real quick
now she used to smoke weed but then she
got put on pins
which is like kid probation
and when she came
but for when you're underage
she started getting [ __ ] freaking out
whenever she would smoke leaves oh
it caught you bad i've had something
i don't know why that i've had some
friends that's happened too
yeah i used to be fine and then i
stopped i had to stop smoking for like a
year and a half and then i tried again
and i just
couldn't handle it that sucks
i know he still tries to get me to do it
all the time i'll walk up to her she's
just talking my regular adult [ __ ] and i
just blow it
he's trying to be a positive influence
and [ __ ]
yeah i think you don't do
fun
you know just seeing if it works yet at
some point she might be like one day
she's like oh my god thank you for that
you know what can i smoke with you
exactly every day waiting for every
night that's why he's doing it also i'm
gonna clean the whole [ __ ] house
right now
you want me to edit
that's what you think is gonna happen
she starts yeah you want to talk about
uh picture profiles and cinematography
caddy here i was wondering what that
yeah i don't know marty no i'm dumb um i
have some notes here and i didn't write
them so i'm just actually asking them
like
questions
okay all right first time i wrote the
notes you did huh this is the first time
it's an all caps that's how i know it's
you but the title isn't super small
[ __ ] it's super small but everything
else is 24 size 5
all right here we go you ready marty
wrote these so get mad at him
are you ready
i see the next thing says psychotic x
and i'm assuming it's not marty no
he's the gentleman right before me
yes so
i was right before him i was in like a
three and a half year relationship it
was actually my first relationship
really yeah i didn't date in high school
i didn't like i just didn't want none of
that i saw all my friends going through
[ __ ] i just wanted to be like
a free person so i didn't i wasn't i
didn't have no boyfriends nothing
and as soon as when i was 17
i met this guy
and
um yeah he was just a [ __ ] psycho
from the start from
no i mean after the first couple months
he she liked him right yeah i liked him
a lot and then we got together after the
first couple of months i realized what a
[ __ ] psycho he was but i felt like i
was already in like too deep he's like
one of those um
situations where
you know like you should threaten to
break up with him he's like crying and
doing all that all right
you're like i have no idea
that sucks yeah so he would so this dude
was crazy to the point where i would try
to break up with him
and let's say for example the one time i
was working at a hotel
and he came to the hotel i was working
there at night
and i have like this big basket of
laundry that you're supposed to fold he
comes in and he's like oh word where are
you gonna break up with me
and like came in there and tried to
start my laundry on fire like all the
[ __ ] on fire you try to light it like
you just came in doing this yeah
i was trying to light the sheets and
stuff it's gonna take a minute
oh yeah as you're screaming out how
threatening is that
[ __ ] you
not to mention that he rode a bike
he rode a bike with a lighter he stole
someone's bike so i had like broke up
with him
he caused a scene at a party we were at
whatever so i just like ended up leaving
him there i'm like i can't even deal
with you i don't want to be with you
he was like a year older than me oh
she's both just kids though yeah we were
and uh
he ended up stealing a bike and riding
it and it was like
probably like
15
your [ __ ] work
you should have heard him out
15 miles on a stolen bike i know looking
over your shoulder every two seconds
so somebody one of the one of the people
sitting there ended up calling the cops
um but it was like so many instances of
this uh
you know i tried to break up with him
one time another time he jumped on the
back of my car
so i was like driving with him on my
trunk
through town [ __ ]
um when did he get off
i had to pull over and actually the
police came again
you're getting good with that
soundboard's going hard
so
when did he finally leave you alone um
so
well there's a story to that
um tell me
we tell we tell stories here
he tells dory's here sometimes
so i actually
against my okay so there was one time
let me let me back up
so there was i was my senior year i had
moved back in with my mom so
you know we're kind of jumping around
but i'll come back to here so i moved
back in with my mom
yeah but then i went and go live with my
grandma because i just
didn't do it didn't get along so i'm
living with my grandma my senior year me
and my friend i tried breaking up with
him again
meanwhile he lives like an hour and a
half away near my dad in like the next
city how'd you meet
um at a like a nightclub
at 17. how did you get in yeah i was
getting into clubs when i was like 15.
what i had a fake id i knew all the
bouncers everybody just let me in her
club run was done by the time i met her
yeah by the time i was 21.
adult as a kid that happened to me too
yes did too much adult [ __ ] at 15.
exactly that burned out
yeah yeah so
you
he lives an hour and a half away
mm-hmm and what is the story he said
when you finally go
um
he ends up like staying in town i go out
with my friends
i come home
and he's literally it's like
four o'clock in the morning
he jumps out from behind the bushes of
your house of my grandma's house
he'd been there for a minute he'd been
there for a long minute so it turned
like and then there's also this one time
what happened don't don't he jumped out
from behind the bushes yeah and he was
like what the [ __ ] where were you like
it was like an abusive
so he would just ask you where you are
aggressive then leave
i don't remember what happened but i
think my actually i think my grandma
overheard the thing and she's like if
you don't [ __ ] leave i'm calling the
cops kind of well she didn't say that
forward my grandma doesn't swear but if
you don't leave the if you don't leave
you know i'm calling the cops type thing
so
because before that i forgot
i came home again one time and this is
like months of me like trying to get rid
of him and then me being stupid and like
talking to him again a little bit
talking to him and yeah so it's like you
know it's kind of me also but
i came home another time and i go to
i go to go to sleep and i hear snoring
under the bed
he was in my grandma's house underneath
my [ __ ] bed
he fell asleep waiting he fell asleep
waiting for me
yeah
yo
what the [ __ ]
was there any anybody there to beat the
[ __ ] out of this man no my poor grandma
like she was like i'm not gonna be like
grandma
you know like so what happened when you
woke him up i told him get the like he
had to get out or i was going to call
the cops
yeah he did end up getting arrested
eventually um that's some really creepy
[ __ ] to be under the i know
i know
that
rosie knows i check
every room every closet everything every
every time i go to the house
i do that because of that and the sixth
sense i don't want anybody shooting me
but that's the scariest [ __ ] i've ever
heard in my [ __ ] life the fact that
you heard snoring what a [ __ ] i would
have lost my mind not terrifying oh i
would have lost my [ __ ] i probably would
have just died right there
i probably would have died from fright
right then and they're like oh
and just coughing
oh god
so what happened when did he leave you
alone
um just eventually i just kept having to
call the cops call the cops and
eventually one day he just said you know
what he just left me alone yeah
and
but it was it was dragged out for like
months and before this so we had even um
in the beginning of the relationship we
had i moved out of my mom's house as
soon as i graduated well on my grandma's
house
uh and we got an apartment together
so my first apartment first time i ever
lived on my own was with him
oh you guys were attached yeah so it was
like a serious relationship pretty early
on
and then i realized how [ __ ] crazy he
was when we when we started living
together
why is he crazy because you try to break
up with him um yeah because we like
drink together and he just go crazy
thinking i'm cheating on him and like
that kind of thing oh he's a guy yeah
yeah and
he was probably cheating on me basically
for sure if he's asking then right
scared about that
probably doing that yeah i get it
so
our very first apartment together
uh we had lived there only maybe
about a month
and
then um it was halloween night
so i'm i'm 18 at this point oh you said
this i'm so so awesome let's go good
storyteller i can see everything all
right keep going
so halloween it's halloween night
hallows eve
and
um
we all got to go out to the bar
and we come back and mind you i had i
had convinced my friend from
my hometown like an hour and a half away
to come with me
so she comes with me did you go out with
your boyfriend in the bars or just yes
so we always went out together but it
always ended up in like a fight
and
she comes out with me she drives out
there with me and i warn her because we
had smelled this
weird smell
every time we go up in that like we
lived our apartment we lived
above like a corner store this is the
buffalo this is an olean which is like
yeah hour and a half
south of buffalo
and
every time we come up into the apartment
there was like this nasty smell a smell
i never smelled before but it was nasty
like rancid
and i thought maybe my neighbor like
went on vacation left his dog in the
apartment or something to the point
where i even went and knocked on the
door
just to see what was going on
and it was literally
the right across the hall neighbor from
me
but it would only come during certain
times because it was cold so it would
any time it would warm up a little bit
smell it i'd smell it and then be cold
and go away even reached out to my
landlord
so we go out that night
and we come back
and
as we really as we come back
there's like a back entrance to the
apartment
and a front so the back entrance
somebody has to let you in on the inside
so we had come up through the front we
start cooking
something and somebody's like i came up
the back way and your neighbor
he's like just [ __ ] standing there
it's real weird
so
me and my friend were like what
they're like go check it out go check it
out like nobody wants to go look
and so me and her go out and look and we
went out through the back door and the
back door when you close it it locks
behind you somebody has to let you back
in
and we look through his window so like
my windows here
the neighbor's windows here and then the
doors in the middle so we look
and there's like this faint light like a
like a night light and you look and you
can see
the neighbor is just standing there in
the living room when you just first
glance
and then we look a little bit
you know we look closer and realized he
hung himself
so he hung himself from his living room
ceiling and that's what we were seeing
like it looked like he was just standing
there
and that's what we had been smelling
for like almost going on two
weeks oh
that's sad
super sad
i didn't know him i didn't because we
had just moved in so i never i think i
saw him maybe like one time
and it's really sad because for him to
be mis i mean nobody heard from him for
like two weeks
um
until we found him that's really sad
so
you guys came home shit-faced and saw
him faced
yeah this is not the story i thought
that we were about to get right now she
went through a string of [ __ ]
unfortunate string of real [ __ ] weird
things yeah
that is [ __ ] up
so we called the police they had to come
and break the window open because
the door locked everything and the smell
just like rushed out like i'll never
forget that smell oh
so fast forward a little bit yeah so we
started this we started this off on a
different note
continue uh so after that we immediately
moved out of the apartment like we just
couldn't stay there it was really weird
you know yes
creeped me out
so we decided to move to arizona so i
moved to arizona with this guy so
phoenix
i was
not 19 yeah maybe i just turned 19.
why did you just pick arizona his
cousins lived there
was this guy mexican white black black
in arizona yeah
okay they lived in phoenix um wild
i always think of mexican dudes and like
racist white men and trucks
really that's all i think of arizona
i've never really been there sorry
i don't think it's like that okay so you
moved there and how was it um
it was cool for like a minute i was
literally like we moved there about a
month after all that happened i was not
i kid you not was there for
only a couple days
and
we're just walking downtown phoenix
we're just checking out everything and
this guy
just jumped off a building
right in front of us
you guys are hips getting the worst the
worst
so i'm like what the [ __ ] like i am not
supposed to be with this dude like the
universe like people don't they go their
whole lives without seeing [ __ ] like
twice a month twice in a month in two
different states
so after that was just like i went home
going home
only lasted like another two weeks there
but
it was just super traumatic
um
so then i went home
and i just tried to break so then he
followed me he was there for like a
couple more weeks i'm like i can't do
this i try to break up with he followed
me he's like i want to make it work
and um
it took me like two months to really try
to break it off with him he would just
come to where i'm from
even though he's an hour and a half away
and just like like fall asleep under my
bed hide in the bushes all asleep under
my bed you saw like you're introducing
him two payments of 9.99
fall asleep under my bed
fight my grandma jesus christ so he fell
asleep on your bed creepy as [ __ ] he
jumped out ah
tried to scare you in the bush didn't do
anything like harry mandel no he didn't
try to scare me you just came out no i'm
that's what i'm imagining he just jumps
ah
no
so what what finally made him leave you
said just enough
yeah enough calling the cops he just
left you alone yeah and then he started
leaving me i mean
does he even still he'll still randomly
send me messages stop it just as recent
as five months ago what does he yeah he
had to block him and everything yeah
he's like i know you're married and
um
no disrespect but let me just disrespect
you
okay so he didn't find anybody else i'm
assuming no he did he has like three
more kids four four kids now god with
two different girls
yeah
all right well anyway it made life so
much easier for me coming into the
equation i was like thinking her family
her mom's side is all cookie cutter and
[ __ ] i'm coming through with the [ __ ]
5x yt's and all my homeboys and [ __ ] and
they actually [ __ ] were like thank
god someone that's not a psychopath not
a psycho why did he have a screw in his
hand
they were cool i was like self-conscious
for the first couple months i remember
really yeah for sure they loved marty
you put on the front
no
okay
no they were just so happy that i was
out of that other relationship
because it was like after after i broke
up with him then that's when like all
the fighting started like i'm fighting
everybody and
oh she had a two year span before you
met marty from him that's when you start
beating everybody's ass mm-hmm
and then you guys i mean there's a
couple there's there's like a couple
instances before then but she was
downtown i was downtown every single
night i was just being real reckless
hanging out with people that were
reckless
because i don't know i just like when
you go through [ __ ] and you're not
really you're not thinking about
yourself you're not thinking about
consequences you're just
i don't know how to explain it
hey what's up guys just taking a break
from the episode to tell you about one
of our sponsors this is manscaped and if
you're an active listener here on dope
as usual you already know what man's
game is about it's for your dick and
balls so guys with christmas right
around the corner take advantage of this
code take advantage of our link right
now go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola and
that's 20 off plus free shipping on
anything on the site manscape has a
section called lifestyle products and
it's perfect for stocking stuffers and
all these things aren't for your dick
and balls they got lip balm which is
definitely not for your balls they got
underwear the shirts they have the shed
which is actually the bat you've seen it
on our channel before the carrying case
that's the shed as i said before
christmas is right around the corner so
don't be like me two days before
christmas and i'm over there taking
every single gift certificate i can buy
at the store be smart be cool and get a
discount all right get a discount use
our code manscape also offers something
called the peak hygiene plan so
basically every three months they will
send you it's like a subscription-based
thing they send you the re-up new blades
refill on gels and powders and shaving
cream but it's also a really good way of
trying out the new products we don't
know only you know maybe you need a [ __ ]
load of ball wipes so get the hygiene
plan you can get it every three months
shipped to your door if any of this
interests you guys go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola and
that's gonna get you 20 off plus free
shipping on anything on the site guys
thank you so much for listening to me
talk about dick and balls for all of
2021 this year is almost over so thank
you so much for being here thank you for
supporting and thank you for supporting
the brands that support us
what's up guys just want to say a
special shout out to one of our sponsors
this is on it alright guys it's
christmas time and anna is doing
something super special this is called
12 days of fitness right now if you go
to their instagram check out the
giveaway flyers that they've been
posting read the directions on the post
but like comment and follow on instagram
and you can be entered in the giveaway
and one of the prizes is super super
dope marty has one of the coolest on
dumbbells i've ever seen the iron man
one but they're giving away right now
super super cool spray painted dumbbells
they're all christmas themed so right
now maybe you can win a giveaway and get
the coolest christmas present for
somebody so if any of this interests you
at all go to
www.onit.com that's
onnit.com forward slash yola that link
will get you 10 off of anything on the
site that's the supplements the
nutrients packs the clothing everything
but the weight sets and right now they
have the daily immune formula that's the
viratech this is basically a shot of
immunity boosting vitamins and for
everyone out there remember they do have
the subscription base packs so once
again guys that's
www.onit.com that's
dot com forward slash yola and like i
said that's 10 off of every single thing
on the site but the weights
sorry i see a
a note in here too
marty you're so vague
it's like the chapter of a book
psychotic x getting stabbed
seeing horrible things yeah it was the
dead people yeah oh god
multiple suicides inside a month inside
of one month
it's a sign she didn't really describe
that second one i feel like and it's the
homeboy like landed
right on the ground
he almost landed on top of you it was
like a 20-story building it was landed
on youtube yeah for sure more so close
to another woman that was holding her
baby
like if he would have landed on them
definitely
yeah
oh that's so sad
yeah oh heavy duty [ __ ] his
yeah it wasn't a pretty sight i mean he
like there were things all over the road
yeah once it's that high you pop
basically oh that's sad bro yeah so i
think it's like a combination of like
just just growing up and like those
things i'm just like [ __ ] it
who gives a [ __ ] anymore you know and
just like led me down to like just go
out every night and
we were both desperate for a change when
we met each other like we were both so
ready for it so ready because i like i
always knew what i wanted for myself i
just
i was just surrounding myself around the
wrong
people yeah of course you know and i
didn't know how to get out of it but i
think once i set that intention
that's when he came into my life and
i just i i knew
you know
and i think that's super important is no
matter what you go through in life no
matter what happens no matter what you
do
you know there's always
if you want different for yourself you
can have different for yourself
you're not defined by
everything you've seen experience or
everything that you did let's go
yeah that's a great way to put it
it's completely true and i think a lot
of people don't think that way and
that's why they just dwell on everything
for sure it's it's really easy to i feel
like beat yourself up and like
you know constantly think about all the
things you did that that screwed up and
and all that but
you know on the flip side like
if you're
ready to change that you
can change it i think we both i remember
like right before i was really like
asking i like i really wanted it i
wanted a solid girl i was in my mind
like picturing like manifesting
visualizing without knowing that's what
i was doing
and speaking it out loud even in my boys
and [ __ ] and then when it happened it
was like
i respected it so much like even as a 19
20 year old dude like i respected my
relationship with her so much because i
asked for it it's like and then once we
had ariana immediately it was just like
you gotta
it's like smacking the face to god like
i said but disrespect this [ __ ]
question
how did you tell marty that you were
about to have a
baby
so cl so early out how long were you
guys dating before you four months whoa
where were you at what'd you do how did
you tell him i get i guarantee wasn't a
[ __ ]
tick tock gender reveal surprise wasn't
anything cool as [ __ ]
i don't know
you guys don't remember
it must have been devastating oh okay
okay let's do this it was it wasn't
devastating oh god i think it was
probably a [ __ ] i don't want to say
dollar store pregnancy test and weirdest
it was a dollar it was probably
something like that
yeah
actually did you buy two to make sure
since it was a dollar store yeah i think
so okay actually i probably stole the
dollar
cuffed us a little six pack of them
things
oh forget it
i love it so much
i love it so much dude it's
hilarious i probably stole my pregnancy
test
oh
maybe a sign you're not ready for a kid
yeah yeah definitely i'm going to spend
a dollar
yeah
[ __ ] i know that's a good early warning
sign
so how'd you tell barney do you remember
i don't really remember i really don't
either i think it was just it wasn't i
was just like yeah i just i think i'm
pregnant and then we went checked and
we're like all right we're gonna we both
like for some reason just knew it was
okay we were like it's okay
because by that point like a four months
seems like very short but when we were
together for like this dude came stayed
the night at my house and didn't leave
that's what he said i went around one
time and never left
he said
she was never my girlfriend she morphed
right into my fiance and then
that was it even before i proposed to
her yeah that's because you didn't put a
ring on it and i felt better saying
fiance listen we
yeah bring it up we already talked about
it
you [ __ ] up you should have been here
yeah yeah it was a couple years yeah
yeah martial
for years to get that [ __ ] ring going
but yeah yeah it's all good i love you
[Music]
so
how'd you meet marty
on myspace
on myspace
oh you saw a straight build hat and a 5x
white team okay
what's ironic is she saw that [ __ ]
g-unit i saw the g-unit instagram want
the shirt
with the shirt right
yeah yeah
i did i was like dang he's from buffalo
he's like a rapper he yeah he was at the
g unit studios and then
but the only reason that's not why i
reached out
i saw that he had a mutual friend
that i also knew
and we started talking like that it was
[ __ ] goofy yeah yeah so goofy intro
to us a via myspace friendship goofy
i never would have thought you'd make an
appearance in your whole
life he steered your whole life
literally brought you out here
crazy
pops in and makes a big [ __ ] turns
out he's working with our ad agency and
he's running
oh [ __ ]
so you met him through him you saw him
on myspace and you guys met up i sent
him a message
we started exchanging messages we met
for the first time and mind you i went
to college for a little bit i did try
tempted ecc
it's a community college it's just right
it's a [ __ ] college it's okay people
do the bills tailgating in the ecc
parking lot
[ __ ] is i'm on april side with this
merced i went to merced community
college talking [ __ ] always talking
about the high school of college oh you
thought you played soccer yeah that's
not great though
send you a newspaper clipping all i'm
saying is listen all right hold on i'm
going to let you finish
here we go here's the facetime
conversation
apparently apparently marty doesn't
believe that he should play soccer
and marty was a star and only scored one
point so they caught they talked about
[ __ ] uh-huh but madame shooting a
thousand it was three points by the way
yeah i mean one basket three worth three
points actually that's how he got me too
and then he's like i was a big
basketball player
that that [ __ ] was true yeah
yeah so
i actually was like uh soccer
actually let's let's talk tell them what
a star are you wearing just like an
athletic
natural
talent
is that where cam gets it from exactly
that's where the sun is that's what you
have you think
you have yourself
i played soccer i played basketball i
was just always
good at it and i i got moved on to
varsity in eighth grade oh shocker
and
he always wants to talk so much to it
like i did not i was never good at
soccer so he's always having me like oh
well so my stepdad he was big on taking
video like on his cam cam corner like
back in the day constantly and he's like
it's not [ __ ] true cause
have to cut that out you just bleep it
he doesn't have it on video yeah
right so basically he's like yeah
if if it were true it'd be on video no
because
we weren't cool
so then i had to call my dad up
and he didn't have any newspaper
yes he did he sent me a picture of when
i was in the newspaper
and still what did it say though
uh
it was like april barber top goal scorer
scores the winning goal like something
legit and he's like
nope
[Laughter]
she went to a school listen there was 50
kids in her graduating class
[Laughter]
marty won't let her have this there
wasn't
i went to that school for one year i
always [ __ ] with her i'm like babe your
school had dirt floors i'm sorry
you really did you actually don't even
never even played [ __ ] soccer yeah
so where's your where's your tape smarty
she's an athlete listen where's your
basketball tapes i didn't have a goddamn
camcorder okay you asked the streets
about me they know you asked the streets
about me man you know like all him yeah
he's caught that one point
he's got the highest shooting record in
school history at damon right him yeah
oh yeah about a thousand all right i
will give you that but this is the part
i was going to ask
you why don't you
you know what you should do
before this video airs get that
newspaper clipping and make him edit it
in there
all right i would i would love to see
that marty you guys have known each
other for how long have you never shown
him no i did show him got it there's a
legend he's still there he's still talk
[ __ ]
no you read it
he read it i don't remember oh marty no
i can see on your face you're like yeah
i did no he literally just like talked
[ __ ] to talk [ __ ] she's an elite athlete
but this is this is what you gotta you
gotta give your partner [ __ ] you gotta
be able to be sarcastic like but he's
like sometimes i do kind of
i gotta make [ __ ] up because she's so
goddamn perfect i'm sorry
what do you want me to do out here as
he's [ __ ] editing over your face
wrong as [ __ ]
yo you could do that everything she says
not true not true not true a little
bleep
yeah
fact check
yes
it's just freeze frames
not true just cuts to me in my garage
just like it's not true
[Laughter]
that's your [ __ ] smoke into the crush
yo okay let's get let's get back on this
i have oh you met marty he has moved in
had had a baby
fast
super fast super fast and now we're
caught up because we've heard almost
everything after that
from you not everything but
a lot we've heard a lot
so this is what we're going to circle
back to because we just we wouldn't even
smoke any weed yet and i just ranted
you get kicked out of your house at
eight in eighth grade oh my god we did
rant oh yeah [ __ ] story i brought it
back let's go okay all right
wow what happened eighth grade you got
kicked out and said you have to move
with your dad
yeah so you got to go live with your dad
but i was like excited oh yeah you know
i was like you almost did it on purpose
now exactly so that's what kind of where
i was going with it but my poor mom you
know
she she tried but you didn't think you
tried to hide the
the car messed up i would have like no
because i slammed the trash can but i
was taking the trash down like [ __ ] the
whole i'm so sorry yeah
i don't know i would have i would have
ran away i literally like didn't give a
[ __ ] there was like some other issues
other than it just being split out and
they hated each other there was there
was
some undiagnosed mental health issues on
that side and
um on your mom's side yeah
on my mom's side
there was just a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that happened that really
pushed me toward my dad
and then i went to go live with my dad
and then
you know that
there was just a lot of [ __ ] that i
shouldn't have seen and
my dad realizes that now he's always
been he's like my number one biggest fan
he says i'm so proud of you and that you
know he realizes a lot of [ __ ] that he
texts i love you i love you like every
[ __ ] day
cool and if i don't if i don't respond
back
he'll like just call me off the hook
but he's i mean he's good now
so but growing up i'm assuming he was
just
drunk yeah he just was like involved in
the same lifestyle that he grew up with
you know he he
didn't i
don't want to say knew any better but he
just wasn't
he was more of my friend
yeah so my dad wasn't as from ten to
what as you lived with your dad
i didn't live with him until i was
almost 12. oh so 12 yeah i thought you
kicked out in eighth grade you have to
move with your dad yeah i was almost 12.
oh wow okay so i'm saying after 10 i
really didn't oh
when you started i was like honestly it
was like making
their life hell i feel like
and my mom and my dad so they're like
hey yeah you got to go yeah we have two
other kids we get to sacrifice this mean
one right now
got you yeah so you went with your dad
mm-hmm how was that at 12 that's when
you started chilling with everybody but
before it was just on the weekend and
now it's like yo what's up fools i live
here
oh my gosh it was like a student the
night i got there i was like i got there
at like 9 00 9 30
at night on a weekday and i was like
instantly i'm like all right dad see ya
and i went up and told all my friends i
was there and all my friends
they're like two three two three years
older than me
at that point um
and it just it just turned into a
situation where
i was just i was literally out i was in
eighth grade i would not even come home
at night
my dad would try
to check up on me
wonder where the [ __ ] i am
and he and i would just a drink or i
wouldn't come home and he you know act
upset the next day but there was never
really any like
repercussions for that
so i just i literally did what the [ __ ]
i wanted did you stay in school i i did
stay in school damn
i know and i i actually got kind of
decent grades maybe that's why he wasn't
too pissed
so from 12 to what aj you live with your
dad only for that year because i got so
much trouble
with your dad
that's the year i was put on pins
i got um
me and my friend a couple friends went
and did like some spray paint graffiti
at the dugout we're like drawing like
dicks
which like digs on the baseball player
and
just dumb [ __ ] yeah stupid [ __ ] just
dumb [ __ ] and um
the police got involved and
yeah
so pins is the drug program we have to
sit there and
piss in a cup every month yeah i did
have to do that oh yeah so at that at
that i feel like even at that age i was
like [ __ ] i don't wanna like i could
have stayed with my dad i could have but
even then i'm like [ __ ] i just really
don't want this anymore because i was
like literally out every single day
every single night
just wasn't about that life anymore and
then um at 12 at [ __ ] i was like 12
years old like
14 almost 15 by this point because i had
lived with him for
a year
um
and then i wanted to go back and live
with my mom
so like 14 you go back with your mom
almost 15. almost 15. uh-huh and then um
i was on pins
because of that situation
and then me and my mom just could never
get along she was like always calling
the officer to drug test me
and everything even though i wasn't like
smoking weed or anything at that at that
point so was your stepdad any cooler
after you came back no [ __ ]
yeah so it just just wasn't a good
situation i was always i feel like i was
always constantly trying to like get out
of my mom's house even though i knew
like looking back that was probably the
best structure for me
but it just
she was too young i was
you know it's i assume it's very
difficult to deal with like two
totally different parents and trying to
get along they really didn't work it out
until deep into our relationship i feel
like
oh you and your mom mm-hmm really so
you're too young or somebody that they
had did you get along with them yeah
they're like they're i mean they're not
even i don't consider them my half
siblings
they're my sisters my little sisters you
know um
and
like i never considered them any
different
but i i get along with them
they're amazing it's like a crazy case
study because she has her two sisters
that live with her stepdad and her mom
and then she has two brothers from her
dad that her dad had nothing to do with
that it did not i mean one of them
that's he's fine but the other one that
did not turn out well for [ __ ] all
no he's he him and so my two brothers
i've met a couple times one is doing
very well with his life in the army
yeah he's done very good and then my
other brother he's in jail right now for
attempted murder
with his mom
they
what yeah they went and tried to rob
somebody for drugs both of them together
because she was always a drug addict
always
like my dad got with her this is the
thing about my dad also
he always dated younger women
so i was 12 13 and i would be friends
with his girlfriends who were like 18 19
years old and your dad's like what 30.
he's like 30 something at this point um
yeah something early 30s
and uh
so then she got pregnant at 18. and had
this brother because you're hanging out
with all the older kids
who's your boy my dad
oh [ __ ] weird
ah
odd
sitcom
okay kind of jerry springer-ish
wild a little weird it's all just
drinking 40s like oh that's my dad
that's my boyfriend uh-huh
okay so she had two kids of the same
lady no too different
oh and then she was a drug
she ended up being like a drug addict um
and and i did to give my dad
credit for he did attempt to like have
visitation with both of them and the
moms made it very difficult
so he just didn't try anymore and he he
should have like
how he did with me but um
that
that brother got mixed up with the mom
he was raised by the grandparents on the
mom's side and then the mom took him
back and she was a drug addict and then
they went and robbed somebody
and he had a gun with him
and during
the robbery the guy got shot so he
and his mom
what a wild court case
yeah
that sucks so your two little sisters
from your mom and stepdad both cool
angels awesome yes turned out really
great so they're like 21-24 25 and 28.
oh they're not that much younger than
you at all
ten and eight years that's not a long
time
i thought they were like 20 years old
i thought they were way way way way i
mean if you think i'm like 29. no i was
insane because we're all like basically
the same age yeah i thought they were
like yeah they're way rocco's to me yeah
no they're all that's why i thought you
when you said her little sisters are
coming down when people say that oh
right i assume like oh is she like in
like
graduating high school or something
oh so you had siblings see this whole
why did i well i mean not really so i
was already like
i got kicked out yeah 14. yeah live with
them for a year came back live with it
and then i was out of the house by 17.
so i didn't really grow up with them
right but
they turned out really well my one
sister moved out here to california she
goes to santa barbara university nice my
other sister she was in school pre-med
now she's traveling they travel like all
over the world they did they did really
well
nice
sexy that's what i was this whole time i
was assuming
math i didn't do good math today okay
you said they had them at eight and
ended when i was ten
so they're obviously eight and ten years
older than you i am [ __ ] burnt you're
tracking a lot of different people right
now yeah i'm trying to keep it all
together and i took a [ __ ] load of dabs
before we started yeah sorry guys
okay so you have siblings do you talk to
your brothers at all no my my older
brother
he's not older than me but the oldest
one i i talk to him here and there
um but not like i don't know it just
really makes me sad i'm really close
with my sisters
so i could have had the same
relationship with them but i didn't
and it's not our fault it's not the
kid's fault no
all all right so
to get on to one more thing real quick
i mean i'm not i'm not done
to my next topic i see in this topic
says edibles gone wrong story
i have a lot of those so what is yours
um it's your only edible story it is
actually
no i've done i've done it
a couple times but that was like my
worst experience ever
so i just can't like like we talked
about i can't handle it he had edibles
my friend was visiting from new york
and we all did it
2015. oh a long time ago yeah like six
years ago five years ago camden was like
one or two
um so
we all did it everybody's having a great
time
no you're not setting the scene properly
at all
uh
something happened we were [ __ ]
watching ufc or something everybody's
basically ready for bed i had some
chibachews i'm eating the [ __ ] chiba
chews like i'm not even thinking twice
about yeah
i offered them a piece of the chibichu
you shouldn't do keep going okay so now
i sliced this [ __ ] thing so thin
i sliced the end off it like if it was a
loaf of bread it was the last like it
was a loaf of bread
i'm talking about the piece was so
[ __ ] small it would almost dissolve
in your fingers like that he's
exaggerating it was a [ __ ] tenth of a
chiba okay okay
that's what she's talking about we're
she's sitting here we're all sitting out
doing the edibles and [ __ ] all right
she had a [ __ ] little slice of this
thing and started her friend
god
well i like that setup
go ahead
okay they're going to tell the whole
[ __ ] story no no you go
okay so i think i had more than that
because strawberry size like literally i
feel like it was a lot bigger than that
anyway
um
everybody's fine everybody's chilling i
was fine until we went to go to bed
and then i start freaking out
in bed yeah in bed i start like
panicking
i start thinking um that him and my
friend had like a plot to come here and
poison me and kill me
get it right out of here
that's where it took me i was so [ __ ]
up did you tell this to marty as you're
[ __ ] up no
not yet because that was so [ __ ] up
like obviously i know that i'm [ __ ] up
and thinking like i know that so i i go
in the bathroom and i'm like looking in
the mirror like you're so [ __ ] up like
trying to talk myself out of it
so then i like i and then i hop in the
shower because i'm just trying to like
compose myself
and i had just gotten a spray tan too so
when you get a spray tan you're not
supposed to shower for a couple like the
next day okay and then i hop in and all
the [ __ ] springs
it's just
going down the drain and i'm like
what's wrong with me
and i'm like hopping out of the water
and like it was just so [ __ ] up you're
half orange dripping it's melting off in
the shower yeah it was so [ __ ] up so
what is the thing and then i got out of
the shower and then i had to come tell
him i thought i was dying she woke me up
and what i do
you laughed at me
i would try to wake him up
i'm at the edge of the bed like oh my
god i've never seen somebody actually i
think you need to call the ambulance
[Music]
so he laughs at me and i'm like that's
not helping
and it just i had to explain to her this
is a thing that happens to some people
yeah and then that's why i think that
i'm like they're plotting on me they're
trying to [ __ ] kill me because i
think i'm dying and he's trying to
convince me that i'm not dying oh so you
think he poised me mm-hmm oh you're my
friend oh you want to hang out my friend
more
is trying to kill me
we got kids
we have two children at this point yeah
so that's why sorry
no edible no edibles
that's a disclaimer chiva chews make you
think your [ __ ] husband's plotting to
poison you went out of business not that
long after that i'm pretty sure uh chiba
shoes i thought correct me if i'm wrong
i think pretty sure they were selling
black market trap
they got caught they got caught selling
trap packs
and edibles but i could be completely
wrong i can't remember the article i saw
a couple years ago sorry cheap jews if
it's not you
anyway um
awesome yeah i've had some experiences
like that
done rso experiences i've had like that
really
oh no i've
i've thrown up a lot got the spins get
pale i'll freak out off an edible i feel
like everybody can hear my [ __ ] i
have to address my heart beating out of
my chest right now because everybody
knows
well you've heard my edible stories i've
had some [ __ ] up times
but that's thousands of milligrams and
that's just insane
but our tolerances are different yes
apparently
i see it since it was such a small
little guys
like complete opposites marty at this
next next time already tells the stories
and but i gave her no she would choose
for years i've been telling her that it
gave her it it was a starburst kissed
her and she was [ __ ]
she smelled it and just got all scared
so i see another note that's a little
more intense what's up with this
mushroom strips
it finally worked it did she had tripped
before me
you know before we met actually no just
one time when i wasn't there she and
before we met before you yeah yeah
and both times really fun time had i had
a good time it was like
it was in an environment where there was
my first time was multiple people which
thank god it went okay everybody was
enjoying themselves
everybody was just laughing having a
good time
and then i did it again at it's this
thing called the regatta
it's you float down the river oh yeah
like this [ __ ] in italy right yeah like
i mean i don't know it's in like a tube
in your [ __ ] face yeah like you [ __ ]
roll down the river in a floatie the
buffalo version yes and there's like
three keg stops along the way
so people are doing like keg stands and
oh buffalo gets wild
it's alcoholic culture and this is deep
in the country she's talking about oh
okay okay so you just have a canal where
people get [ __ ] that's it's boring out
there hey you want a drink yeah but what
if we just got in the [ __ ] river
yes and it's a whole thing there's
thousands of people there
so we did it while we were there
me and me and my friend
actually the friend that found the body
with me oh so we're still friends
luckily
and then this recent one
mushroom trip okay so this recent one
i saw all sorts of she ate that [ __ ] and
then she's like she ate it she looked
around and she's like
i can see another dimension he's like
almost immediately describe what you saw
within like 25 minutes i was seeing and
i had number like i've been like the
body high and i see colors more vividly
and stuff got a good time this one
really got me and by the way i'm sorry
i'm sorry
my bad
i gave you an edible i mean i gave you
the mushroom bar
and it's the other mushroom bars that
have two grams the ones i gave you guys
have four grams that was good and i
didn't realize until after you guys told
me how hard you tripped i gave you
double the doses by and
see how things happened it wasn't even
intentional and i accidentally double
dosed it it was the perfect
because i definitely went into it not
expecting that at all i was just like
okay she's going to be mildly like would
you say hi within 20 minutes
i was sitting out on the porch and it
started like i saw inside um
inside the dining room and i was looking
at the table and all the lights were
like flashing
so much brighter and it looked like
i don't know it just looks like a
three-day
dimensional thing and i was like oh [ __ ]
like this actually
is doing something
and then i started seeing like
geometrical shapes
never
saw that before mom
she was just cool though right
yeah it was really cool did the stars
move mm-hmm stars were moving they
looked like they were connected like you
touch them
did you move them oh [ __ ] that's my
favorite thing just to do this well i'd
that never wiping a table with salt all
over it
i was completely [ __ ] sober she's in
another dimension this [ __ ] she's bigger
god hit me yeah yeah yours hit later i
was getting frustrated she said she's
awful i'm in another dimension
oh my god and then i'm like come in the
bathroom with me
you can see like you can see like wash
your hands just wash your hands it's
weird feeling is
then like seeing my hands it looked like
i was like little person hands on a
different body like i felt sorry body
far away yeah so i save everybody i
always feel like my arms starts to growl
or i always tug the bots the bottom of
my shirts because i feel like it's like
a long cape
it feels like it's going to keep
stretching like the pee wee herman chain
when he's locking his bike up and just
keeps going that's how i felt about my
clothes on mushrooms so what else did
you see you saw geometrical shapes
um
i i think that was just like i don't
know just like
the shapes and bright colors and
just trying to process everything like
definitely looking at the sky was crazy
actually the palm trees turned into like
[ __ ] everything like you're in a
roblox do you know the roblox game i
heard of it all [ __ ] boxy shapes and
that's what that's what the
palm trees start looking like i like
looking at street lights because you
know when you look at the street line
you look away and it kind of gets it
kind of stays in your eye for a couple
seconds
that shit's crazy once you start
tripping i was getting frustrated
because it wasn't hitting me and then
that's right so it hit us at different
times i by the time it started hitting
him i feel like i was starting to like
not it was worse yeah so then he's just
right i'm like done and he's randomly
like
and when you're done
videos by himself oh please i was going
[ __ ] hands oh please
i had the pink floyd going i was
bursting out and [ __ ]
he tried to show it to me like look how
[ __ ] funny is this
it was funny to me because i could
picture the dude putting it together and
what how random like if you watch
money shine on you crazy all the crazy
[ __ ] that's coming in [ __ ] just just
stop cutting it just stop [ __ ]
and i was just like bursting out like
he's laughing at the bad editing it was
amazing it's just cynical
you [ __ ] [ __ ] in 1974
because you know how to use final cut oh
you [ __ ]
on mushrooms
and then he shows me what he's laughing
at i'm like this is [ __ ] creeping me
out i can't wait
it's good [ __ ] though it is good [ __ ]
like but then i was already like done
and once you're done off mushrooms and
you decide that you're done the night is
done
i have a hard time going back to regular
life after mushrooms it's weird
you gotta go to sleep and i've never
done again
i do mushrooms all night
and i wake up and just the whole next
day's like
i'm [ __ ] up like i'm off
so pretty much you went to sleep and
when you went to sleep that's when
marty's night started kind of yeah
i'm done i just like passed out on the
floor and then oh yeah so you guys are
swimming on different parts of your
house yeah yeah yeah touching textures
it was cool it was cool with her away
because we could talk and the music was
going the music was really hitting and
[ __ ] random music i wouldn't normally
listen to it was perfect
and then i just started camping out in
different spots of the house i'm up
against the [ __ ] mini fridge it's got
that blue light going i'm [ __ ] i got
the [ __ ] i had a video going of the
uh you know like a astronaut soaring
over earth
and then i went outside it was [ __ ]
freezing cold outside i'm sitting on the
porch meanwhile my police neighbor's
probably staring outside [ __ ] i'm
staring up in the skies
dumbfounded for i don't know how long i
was just staring up in the [ __ ] sky
laser light show going down love it
full-blown
star i'm seeing constellations connected
and there's like a web that's kind of
breathing like elastic amongst the stars
the stars are flickering so fun it's so
fun but like literally you can only do
it once in a while oh you have too much
if you have too much responsibility it's
it's yeah it's almost impossible to do
mushrooms yeah it's very you have too
much [ __ ] to worry about or too many
people to take care of i would never do
it again where it's not like a
completely chill thing where it's just
uh well you guys didn't expect it to hit
you because the last time it didn't work
i had been waiting for this for [ __ ]
a long time you know it was just yeah i
didn't want to
i didn't want to go too overboard with
the [ __ ] off the bat yeah of course of
course
well that sounds bomb that was awesome
i'm glad you guys i'm glad to hit you
guys thank you of course [ __ ] yeah yes
thank you so
what else do you want you have marty do
you have anything you want to say or any
stories or anything you want because
obviously you know a lot more than i do
sir
look at that
yeah it feels great to like put your
[ __ ] truth out there after last
week's episode like that was just such a
relief and so many people
wrote
the comments the messages i got from
last week's episode dealing with death
too is
[ __ ] everybody getting people the
exact same thing to the d
yeah and this i know what this episode
is it's going to have the same effect on
people going through all the [ __ ] that
she's been talking about i just think
it's really funny
that youtube looks so [ __ ] innocent
i just just for me no like
if i was at a flag football game saw cam
like oh it's can't experience
we do look pretty [ __ ] wholesome you
guys truly look like a hallmark family
we are i mean
i'm talking about from your from the
stars
yeah cause over here you're over here
yeah i know i punched dudes in the
[ __ ] mouth and over here no i'll stop
[ __ ] actually i carry a screw and
like then you guys just happened to meet
because of a g unit shirt and a big ch
both of you guys
get ready what'd you say i bump dmx when
i'm on my way to a sale yeah
that's right i'm ready to go door
knocking and uh getting the zone out
bumped dmx or sometimes they'd even do
corn nice yeah
that's a that's a total yeah genres but
i i
i love them both so that's fine you guys
are very similar like that she's
obsessed with corn but she'll throw out
some hip-hop [ __ ] everyone swab that
that's why i married ya and last time
every once in a while i know every
single all the time i'm trying to give
you some credit here she puts on
something i'm trying to give you some
credit here while discrediting actually
we like talk about this when we're
driving the car i know so many genres of
music like rock old school call thomas
see if thomas knows no no no i hear that
oh no you don't know this song like
just a song i think you should
definitely know from the [ __ ] 60s
that uh her dad was playing i'm sorry
but your dad was playing that [ __ ] too
so i think he's yeah so i grew up lucky
my mom knows all that [ __ ] that's why
yeah
yeah i think i'm just like kind of
surprised you don't know the songs i'm
like i bet you thomas [ __ ] knows that
i get that call she's april said i bet
you thomas knows i've got to probably
like 40 of those calls at least
for real yeah at least about 40 of those
calls and about 90 of the time i know he
makes fun of me he's like yeah
i don't know 60's i didn't grow up in
the 50's paul thomas and asked him if he
knows about the bee gees and [ __ ] of
course yeah i love the bees
they played uh
sergeant pepper's lily hearts club they
were the main characters
boston's great yeah
he didn't even know the sun
it's crazy to me that your dad didn't go
no no
martin lawrence
listen
to this song the fact that he didn't
force it on you was kind of wild to me
that's all that's why i'm so lucky i
grew up on uh now that's or remember the
uh commercials at late night and they go
and one old rock musician and one some
young girl that's never heard the songs
and they tell you about here on the disc
149 you're going to get 17 cds with all
of these hits and it shows the zombies
i would watch it all night and then i
started lime wire oh [ __ ] yeah i should
use the lime limewire to download all
the oldies so as a kid
and my grandpa so i and then i got into
rap later so yeah like you i know a lot
of different [ __ ] so it's always weird i
know it is kind of odd like you don't
know this song hear me a rapper yeah
it's always a big figure people that do
music know everything i thought i knew i
thought i [ __ ] knew everything until
i like
met other people
until i left my house i thought i'd do
all of it
marty was
[ __ ] water boy
my mom said that
what they're the only band
those in harmony
and harmony
actually my grandpa you know that song
i actually got in a fight at the bone
thugs concert oh they stopped the
concert because you were fighting
somebody yes let's go why did you it was
like a small venue though um and me and
my friend we were like in the front and
these girls thought they were at like a
rock concert they were moshing they kept
hitting into us
and we told the bouncer or security
they made note of it they kept doing it
like intentionally and then
it's just like she pushed me into the
gate thing and then we just started
rocking them
and they stopped the whole concert
they're like [ __ ] boys
that's gross yes i have a lot of
um
so what i take away from this is
hey you have your head in your shoulders
you beat the [ __ ] out of people you may
or allegedly sold some stuff
your dad seems pretty cool
[Music]
all right that's what i'm taking from
this yeah fiona of
shameless over here just
jesus christ like no i'll drive you home
again
can you drive me to third grade tomorrow
shameless hit so [ __ ] hard that first
season
oh my gosh i don't even know if i can
watch this that that damn
shameless it's so it's so wild because
people always think of
like growing up hard like oh you live in
the hood oh you're mexican full living
in the hood do you never think of white
people struggles of i grew up
with the dad that didn't pay attention
so many ways you know there's so brian
and ethan we got [ __ ] up and did lines
at their house because their mom was
standing there letting us do it
like there's a
there's another side of lack of parents
when it comes to i figure
the way i see it a lot of mexican dudes
always join gang because their parents
are [ __ ] working and they're not
beating the [ __ ] of them and they're
wearing
cortez's and they can't join gangs and
you know what i'm saying
i feel you like the places you're from
like the hood ass areas
parents are not paying attention maybe
lack of money and in the white areas
i've noticed
every time the parents let the kids get
[ __ ] up the house is insane
it's a lifestyle choice yeah but that's
what i've noticed with like
you're either
you got the science fair
or you grew up like you as soon as you
start letting your kid do [ __ ] like that
oh that's that's what i'm saying i can't
break those barriers i won't say what
friend remember we're doing a bunch of
lines
and my friend's mom busts out all this
chris and he goes come on not just do
this with us
i'm 15.
oh she's about to do some chris and then
her other son would get that cheap [ __ ]
out of here mom and he busted out a fat
ass rail and i'm sitting there just like
it smells like cigarettes in here i
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
that's how i grew up with my white
friends
it's crazy
it's pretty much like that yep you grew
up with a was it cold
there's a lot of cans with cigarettes in
it
yes
okay listen
stop
dead
sounds like my friends garages with
their step dads
[Music]
there's an engine somewhere taken apart
i mean yeah the first time i saw like in
that environment i was hanging out with
my friends first time i saw somebody
smoke crack was like 14. oh okay so yeah
you grew up
yeah yeah you grew up like the shitty
kids like us yeah yeah i i was exposed
to all that chat at a very early age now
when i say people smoke crack might
i don't
i don't see but you guys live in a nice
area yeah yeah that's why because you
guys are from the [ __ ] crack smoking
going i saw some crack smoking right
here the other day
wow
she was getting it in the middle of the
day and she was asked she had a sign
on in on this on glendale avenue
right there in that water village and
she's like smiling she looks so happy
like she's like this older white lady
she's like doing this cross-legged and
she's she's torching this crack i'm like
wow she's having the time of her life
right there remember that time that we
were at the at the train station and
that guy dropped his crack pipe
and me and him were just like talking
amongst each other and like oh [ __ ] that
dude just dropped his crackpot you pick
it up and we were laughing like kind of
laughing about it and the
security guard came over and she's like
oh is that [ __ ] funny you laughing at
other people's expense i'm like no
that's literally what i said [ __ ] he
just dropped a crack pipe like sorry
security he'll pick it up security
seriously by smoking
yeah yeah
she tried to go all social justice
warrior what are you guys making fun of
homeless people
and nonchalantly like nothing happened
so yeah it's a little funny sorry this
is funny
math pipes are funny too
especially in front of security guards
their entertainment i'm sorry to put it
that way but crackers do some crazy [ __ ]
i'm sure you guys know that it's fun
so not i mean i mean sometimes the [ __ ]
they do is fun i should say i thought
one time and i like there were certain
things growing up like i still wouldn't
get myself involved like i was [ __ ] up
but there's still certain things that
like
crack snuff like no i was like i never
felt comfortable being around that even
though like i was surrounded by people
like that i tried to keep my distance
and everything and
yeah cracks it's not heroin i've seen
somebody do heroin before i've never
seen any that's the one drug i've never
seen anybody it was a lot worse
no i saw somebody shoot it up
horrible
ew
yeah yeah just a song oh
man first time i saw people like heavy
heavy heavy smoke meth
and just watch daytime tv like that was
the thing to do
that
can watch soap operas
we were in the trailer we were in like a
trailer but it was a big trailer
my friends took me out there
it was big head like a section that went
off like a hall modular home
i don't know what and then we went and
everything looked like after you see
tornadoes
the whole room is just stuff everywhere
and this lady sitting cross-legged and
she's just hitting this pookie
and i'm sitting there and i'm almost
like
and then my friends just start hitting
the pookie with them like
not even the math
she doesn't look clean you put your
mouth on this [ __ ] that's the thing that
got me like yeah dude man
go like that
did you put your mouth on this bitch's
method hey that's the first time i saw
that
i was 14. yeah yeah 14.
yeah so um
all right i think i think we got to some
pretty good [ __ ] right there this is
[ __ ] crazy
that was supposed to be it's clap oh
instead you did
[Laughter]
that was awesome thank you thank you
thank you marty you didn't talk [ __ ]
you didn't go crazy
yeah you did a good job you know just
trying to learn things and my my talk
[ __ ] everybody i mean like you didn't
just make fun of april or nothing crazy
he loves it he does i know she's got a
valuable message she's very powerful
she's
even like in my mom's letter that she
wrote the one thing she said is like
april manifests things faster than
anybody i've ever seen that's true she
puts her mind to some [ __ ] i mean it's
the whole reason why we're here today
is her ability to quarterback things and
make things happen that's uncanny
usually relationships with one or the
other but you guys both do that [ __ ]
you guys are very
much the same
personality type from what i'm seeing
in the terms of like determination yeah
i think we recognize that about each
other right off the bat because she
signed up for a very my biggest thing
like
i want to build goals with you i want to
accomplish things with you and we're
always going to support each other no
matter what we're going to go through
hard times we know that we accept that
but our goal in life is to push always
push forward push forward
and make [ __ ] happen like my my
you know i talk about it and i joke
about it but our life
past life
it doesn't define you
you can feel bad about yourself all you
want you can feel bad about your
circumstances but at the end of the day
like you always have to push
forward know you can make it you know
you're gonna be determined to do
something else
and deal with the [ __ ] that comes your
way it's not always gonna be
not going to be like oh i want to build
a business today and tomorrow it's going
to happen
yeah and that's something that we didn't
talk about either that she runs her own
super successful real estate business i
don't think we mentioned that
no but that's what i meant by you're
bumming dmx and the way it was sale
right exactly exactly so
good
some entrepreneurial [ __ ] to go down for
you let's do it yeah so for everyone
asking what do you do yeah
you sell houses
yeah and she she started out man she
sold her first sale we already know how
we started out to my homeboy she started
out out there selling these little
70 thousand dollar houses and now
they're up in the millions [ __ ] yeah
it's the same path as like drastic
graphics just trying to build bigger and
build better hotels that's like
always the mentality yeah
your kids are lucky to have parents that
are so determined man
for real about to have them on here have
uh yeah cam just does push-ups in the
back
it says burpees and then
we interview emery
[Laughter]
interviewing a little bit when you guys
asked last night about what do they want
for christmas that should touch my heart
like oh i love them bro they're cool
yeah they're awesome
uh i think we already got ariana's stuff
but we haven't got the rest of the stuff
in the mail for the other kids
right yeah yeah okay
well now they know
all right
um
good [ __ ] good job that was great thank
you for
actually doing it cause i know you were
like i don't know i was a little
hesitant like oh is it raining today oh
two day catch ride
oh it ends it's a friday uh we can't do
this fridays
but
i'm really glad that i did it you guys
could have an amazing fan base and
just
and it's good to put a person and a
person to all the stories this
motherfucker's been telling everybody
punching dude to the mouth and beating
the shed people to snow we want to see
what's going on
[Music]
that's a jaw rule song hello hello
exactly
this whole question why you married me
right
wait you know dmx it's a good for
instance right there getting pregnant
[Laughter]
oh all right thank you so much uh thank
you for being here marty thank you thank
you everybody thank you just period just
after that last episode that meant so
much to me
and all everybody's kind words and
[ __ ] was just crazy and
felt right to do this at following that
episode
and we'll get back to normal life here
with [ __ ] adam 22 and dr drew and
everybody else
and it's christmas so everybody be safe
have fun
hang out with your families even if you
[ __ ] don't like them
just deal with it because eventually
you're going to be 40 years older and
going remember we didn't [ __ ] with each
other now we're old hanging out that's
the best thing
like we went to the funeral this morning
like that the only thing i took from
that was like one guy said some [ __ ]
like you gotta hang out with
[ __ ] now like that's a good way
to put it because covert had me thinking
i ain't never gonna chill again
so hang out with your [ __ ] families
it's almost christmas time
be safe april thank you for being here
marty thank you for being here
teenage mutant ninja turtles
out
newscast ryan seacrest out donatello
wait
cowabunga cowbo oh that's what they say
to you at the airport right
all right let's go uh i would never end
this this is like our face times it's
never going to end guys thank you so
much for watching the dopes usual
podcast have a dope ass day yeah that
would have never
ended ever
i just started talking about mute ninja
turtles
[Music]
perfect
[Music]